-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
We're about to play a game
called "What's Behind Me."
My partner tonight
is an incredible actress.
Her new movie, "Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery,"
premieres on Netflix
December 23rd.
Give it up for
the one, the only Kate Hudson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's what I'm talking about!
-Jimmy Fallon!
-Welcome!
-Whoo! We're back.
We're back to playing games.
-We're playing a game again.
Kate, I love you.
-We're playing games.
I love you.
-Kate, here's how
the game's going to work.
We're going to take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the
curtain will be something
neither of us
have ever seen before.
It could be people.
It could be objects.
It could be anything, okay?
Once the curtain opens
and you pick up your card,
you have 45 seconds to get
the other person to guess
what's behind them.
-Okay.
-You can say anything you want.
You can use gestures.
You just can't say any of
the words on the card.
-And we have 30 seconds?
-Yeah.
-Did you say 30 seconds?
-I said 45.
-45. Okay.
-Do you want me to change it?
-Do you want to make it harder?
-I feel like, you know...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Kate, you'll be guessing first.
Let's get into position.
-Okay.
-Look at the budget on this.
-Are we supposed to --
-No, get ready for this.
Just sit and enjoy.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-I'm scared.
-Oh, yeah.
-Whoo!
-Look at this.
This is unbelievable.
This is all of our budget.
All of our budget.
Yeah, now let's open the curtain
and see what is behind you.
-Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm so excited.
It's the number-1
TV show on Netflix, a TV show.
-"White Lotus."
-No, yeah, but, see, it's a --
-"Stranger Things."
-It's a family of...
-On Netflix.
-...scary things.
-Scary things.
Oh, "Wednesday."
-Yes!
Wednesday is with
a person who is a chef
who wears flames on his shirts.
-Oh, Bobby --
-No, it's not Bobby.
-Shoot!
-The other one.
-No, yeah, with the white hair,
the whitish hair.
-Yes.
-I don't know his name!
-No, I know it. I know it.
-If you don't know someone's
name, you go, "Hey, G--."
-Hey...guy.
-Yes!
But what's his name?
-Guy Fieri.
-Yes, that's correct!
And, together, they are
putting together something.
When it's not raining,
but it's --
-It's raining. It's storming.
-In the wintertime.
-It's snowing.
-Yes. What would you make?
What would you make?
-A snowball.
-No, but a bigger one.
-A snowman!
-Yes! That's correct!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
Okay. Okay.
-That is exactly right.
Wednesday Addams and Guy Fieri
building a snowman.
Oh, my God. Well done.
Well done.
That is a very good job.
Good job.
Wednesday, you're very upset.
Guy, nice to see you.
Ooh! Now it is my turn to guess.
Let's rotate.
-I love this. Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright. Here you go.
-Okay.
-Okay, and now let's see
what's behind me.
-This is the best.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay. Okay. Can I go?
Can I go?
-Yes, yes.
-Okay. He's a Marvel --
-I can't even hear you.
-Marvel --
-Oh, Marvel.
Spider-Man.
-No, Mark Ruffalo.
-Oh, Hulk, Hulk.
-Yeah.
And women do this a lot.
And they go and they do it
to their va-jay-jays.
And --
-Bedazzle them?
-No. Well, interesting.
Very interesting.
So, or, you know, it hurts.
Ow! Ow!
-Oh, a Brazilian wax.
-Yeah, or just a...
-A wax.
-Okay, great.
And our president.
-Joe Biden.
-Yeah.
-Wait. So The Hulk
is waxing Joe Biden?
-No. Yeah. No.
No, The Hulk --
-The Hulk is getting waxed.
-Yes. His back --
-Back waxed from
President Joe Biden.
-Yes.
-Alright.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow.
He doesn't look happy about it.
-Fanta--
-He doesn't look happy about it,
but President Biden does,
weirdly.
He's happy about it.
And The Hulk --
Oh, The Hulk is upset.
He's upset about it.
-I love it.
I mean,
president is very pleased.
-Do you think that he went into
this as Bruce Banner
and the pain turned him
into The Hulk?
-Oh, my God.
-I appreciate you guys.
Well done.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here we go. It's your turn.
-Okay.
-You got this, partner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Mmm, ahhh ♪
Alright, let's see
what's behind you.
-I'm scared.
-Okay.
-What is that face?
You're making a face.
-I know one of them.
Alright, it's a -- Okay.
-Okay.
-Alright, it's two men.
One man is cleaning products.
-Oh, Mr. Clean.
-Yes, thank you.
Yeah, kind of. Alright.
I can kind of say -- Eh,
"cleaning products" I can say.
Sorry. Sorry.
Mr. Clean.
-Okay, Mr. Clean.
-Alright.
And then it rhymes with that,
but he's a
British physical comedian.
-Oh, Mr. Bean.
-Yes.
And they're bouncing on
something that rhy--
-A trampoline!
-Yes! Oh, my God!
[ Dinging ]
-Whoo! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Mr. Bean.
-I know, Mr. Bean.
No, it's Mr. Bean.
-I mean, that's pretty good.
-What's he doing?
-He's being a Mr. Bean.
-Yes, he's being very Mr. Beany.
And he's doing -- And then
he winks a couple times
and then he shakes his head
and then he's twisting --
Look, he's twisting
a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, he's shocked.
Mr. Bean is shocked.
Okay, this is great.
Thank you, Mr. Clean.
Thank you, Mr. Bean.
-Thank you.
-On trampolines.
-They're rebounding.
They're rebounding.
-Alright,
this is the final round, okay?
This is a big deal.
This is worth --
-We're winning.
-This is worth all the points.
-Okay.
-So if you're watching at home
and gambling,
please don't gamble on this.
You have a problem.
But this is
worth all the points.
If we win this,
we're champs for life, okay?
-Okay. Forever.
-Forever and ever.
Let's rotate the stage, please.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Alright, here we go.
-It completely rotates.
-Yeah, wait.
Why don't we just turn
our chairs around?
I could face that way.
We spent all this money
on this stage.
We just -- But the chair
can spin around.
Got to work on the budget here.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see --
-Okay.
-Let's see what's behind me.
-Ooh! Okay.
♪♪
Okay. Okay.
Oh! Okay. Alright.
This guy -- Oh!
This guy Austin just played
in the new movie --
-Elvis Presley.
-Okay.
Is playing with a thing
that kids love to play with
on trees at birthday parties.
-A piñata.
-Yeah, but he's also,
instead of the piñata,
hitting a very
Christmasy cookie.
-A gingerbread man.
-Yes!
-Is that correct?
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoo!
-I can watch this
for 25 minutes.
This is fanta--
Elvis, take another -- Hiya!
Oh, come on, do one more, Elvis.
This is worth it.
-I did that really...
-Oh!
Guys, Kate Hudson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be talking to Kate
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.